and you stayed in a different area
during the filming right we're in New
Mexico explain your process for that
when we were shooting don't blink
ariados in New Mexico we had we were
talking off-camera but we had the top of
this mountain it was a developer I was
making sort of like a gated community
where there all these house
opportunities and we had three different
houses up there the big beautiful cabin
that you see the movie shot in and then
this other incredible house another
incredible house do it they were like to
weigh in for the cabin 1.7 1.8 and like
freaking fantastic and I put the ladies
up in this one and the dudes up in this
one and we do director level but as I've
said used it the garage of this one for
catering and because you got a crew of
like 80 people and then you got building
props over here and then over here you
get production and makeup and all that
so every square foot was utilized
luxurious but like utilize and I stayed
down the mountain with my producing
partners Carl Lucas and and Alan Trevor
and also the post-production supervisor
and we would swap out who took the couch
and the reason I want to do that is you
know my cast I put in these beautiful
houses and really the accoutrements are
incredible you've got pool tables and
giant screens and jacuzzis on on decks
overlooking forests and massive valleys
it was stunning and I didn't stay there
for a couple of reasons I wanted my cast
to have a great time I wanted them to be
excited and feel important and that they
were doing something more than the
budget of the film I've done a little
bunch of feature films before as an
actress solely and when I I showed up on
one project and we are you know
Winnebago five Bangor five bangers when
you've got like a little room little
room little room little room little room
right and you've got place for a bed you
walk in the door there's a bed and
here's the sink over here is a toilet
you get the out like that's it
right and I remember coming to work on
the star of this little low-budget film
la twister and the whole thing is
flooded with poop water from the toilet
and I still have to get dressed in there
I'm standing on a Apple box
going over the bed get my done
going like really dude
like really come on look really because
you're not getting any money so you're
supposed to be in it for the art but
it's trying too hard to focus that when
you smell like your own poop that's not
the world that wanted to create so by
putting my actors up in those areas they
felt glamorous they felt we are actors
and they needed that and then by keeping
them away from me and my producing
partner we could go into the the our
building and we could lose our
minds or discuss things and who's a
problem and who's not and how we could
tell the issue without them taking it
personally because you don't want to do
that around them cuz they're not seeing
the overview they're seeing I'm acting
and you might be like you know that's
great but this person spending 15
minutes too long in the chair makeup
chair every day well in 20 days you know
I I can't give him that much time that's
costing me money that's cussing me over
a thousand bucks no we had to trim this
down let's move along who's gonna bring
her breakfast in the chair get her
coffee because if we start with her hair
she could mean in the burrito while that
when she does that then went that must
stay at this time but you don't want to
do that in front of an actor you want to
be there going hey man good morning how
are you you look great all the stuff
looks so good yesterday it's all good oh
God
so they're excited right and also as a
producer I kind of wanted to keep a
separation from the cast so there was a
little bit of difference someone's like
hey guys we got to tighten up get a move
like oh okay yeah that guy's still kind
of a dick even though we're acting with
him all right fine
you